Space discoveries are some of the greatest achievements. Our,
our civilization rightfully takes pride in and today still more
fascinating scientific prospects are looming up ahead,
but what if all these processes are doomed,
destined to be stopped by the greatest threat to our species. And sooner, late,
the depths of the universe will reveal to mankind irrefutable evidence of what
ultimate fate has in store for any living creature,
namely the inevitability of death.
Outer. According to the theory,
we'll be looking at today.
Any intelligent trace is bound to face a number of insurmountable obstacles at a
certain stage of its development.
And the upshots of the development of any civilization is that sooner or later
it is to meet its demise with no traces or NCE of its existence
left behind the hypothesis will be talking about is called the great filter
to estimate the plausibility of such prospects.
We will have to direct our gaze into the future and to speculate about issues
likely to be lying in weight ahead of us,
that we're going to encounter while evolving as a species.
The idea of the great filter hypothesis was first put forward by the economist
Robin Hassen in 1996,
the theory was supposed to account for the Firmi paradox.
Something I told you about in one of our earlier videos,
according to the author,
since there are no traces of extra retrial civilizations to be seen in the
liable part of the universe, it is doubtful.
The chances of the birth of intelligent life forms are high.
And so arguments in favor of this motion have to be seriously questioned.
It is feasible. That factors as yet,
unknown to science may impede the evolution of life forms,
not allowing them to grow into a civilization,
advanced enough to venture into of the cosmos and become a gala to CRA.
If the hypothesis were to be believed such like factors may well get in the way
of our species too, as for the notion of the great filter itself,
it specifies what some of these obstacles may be like chronologically.
They can be either in the past when animals are prevented from evolving to
become species or in the future,
meaning that there is a big hazard of an intelligent civilization,
almost certainly finding itself on the road to self destruction.
In our case, the concept implies that the,
the evolution has occurred until now the worst,
the prospects for humankind appear to be for the future. In other words,
if we still haven't had to deal with our great filter,
it is highly likely we will yet have to do so. At some point,
initially the hypothesis was met with skepticism.
The evolution of species in our planet has been going on rather smoothly,
which means that there may well be,
or may have been for that matter similar conditions elsewhere in the universe.
In addition to that, the Drake equation shows that in the Milky way alone,
there should be at least several dozen advanced civilizations.
At least some of them are bound to have got hang of radio astronomy or
constructed spacecraft. Like our voyages,
consequently interaction with an alien civilization cannot be that elusive.
However,
ever since we've set out in our search for other intelligent traces out there,
the universe hasn't dropped as much as a single hint of anybody else dwelling in
its vast expanses.
The hypothetical great filter may well be the reason for this lack of clues.
The hypothesis suggests that the role of the great filter may be played by one
or several obstacles and advanced civilization has to power through in the
course of its evolution. If a filter of this sort does exist,
that should explain why we still haven't received any signals from advanced
civilizations from elsewhere in the universe.
Incidentally,
the hypothesis admits of the possibility of some creatures surviving the great
filter to do it successfully.
They have to complete several stages to begin with their planet
has to be in the Guild log zone of its parents star.
Next life has to originate and start evolving there with the organisms
capable of multiplying, using molecules like DNA and RNA.
After that single cells have to evolve into more complex ones.
While the evolution of multicellular organisms will be vigorously stimulated
this in its turn should stimulate the development of sexual propagation,
which will be good for genetic diversity.
Eventually this will produce yet more elaborate organisms capable of using tools
for developing to the level of advanced enough technologies necessary for space
colonization.
They will then proceed to colonize other worlds and Stella systems to ensure
survival and obviate the eventuality of self destruction.
Robin Hansen argues that it is then,
and only then that the great filter will become a thing of the past.
Within this concept at the current stage of evolution,
mankind should be bracing up for the most challenging one coming next.
When other celestial bodies are going to have to be colonized for the human race
to survive. However,
it is hardly necessary to point out that the PLAs ability of getting through
with this plan is rather small
been house and maintained that there is a fatal obstacle that an intelligent
species encounters at some of the nine steps of its evolution.
This is supposed to be something definitive that causes total elimination of the
species. Mankind may have completed eight steps of evolution.
The chances of successfully completing the ninth are rather slim.
And that last step may prove to be that very fatal obstacle.
A number of other points are set out in a hypothesis. For example,
it specifies measures that must be taken by civilization to an eliminate,
the risk of self destruction as a result of internal wars,
irreversibly detrimental impacts on ecology and the depletion of natural
resources.
Apart from the exclusively theoretical benefits offered by this reasoning,
it could be really useful for working out our strategies for space exploration,
from the perspective of the great filter theory, proponents,
the discovery of extinct multicellular life forms on Mars should be bad news.
It will imply that most of the steps we've completed so far have been
comparatively easy.
And so the greatest challenge will be posed by the steps still lying ahead of
us.
That is why the years are a hypothetical evolution occurred on other planets.
The higher,
the probability that mankind will never grow to be a space faring civilization,
but actually it isn't all doom and gloom for all we know,
we may have already negotiated our toughest obstacle at one of the steps already
completed for this reason.
Some researchers believe that the fact that we appear to be alone in the
universe is actually a good sign.
This could indicate that we are the lucky few who have passed through the great
filter, quite unscathed, still we can't,
but admit that people use only several forms of communication.
Whereas there may be considerably more of them either way.
The universe is estimated to have existed for 13.8 billion years.
And there may well be a great number of organisms out there that would've
overcome these obstacles,
but hardly any of them will learn that they're not the only ones around for
this. They have to accomplish a major technological breakthrough,
which in theory is to be there undoing and lead to a global apocalypse.
The situation on our planet demonstrates just that we're able to eliminate the
entire human race as a result of a global Thermo nuclear war.
The odds are rather high that our civilization will be wiped off the face of the
earth before either super powerful engines or more effective forms of
communication have been developed.
It is also hard to actually identify the great filter as the environment
on other planets may be completely different from ours.
For instance, a biogenesis,
a process of inorganic nature transforming into organic one is bizarre and
fascinating,
and it may actually be the great filter for many intelligent traces.
Given all this, the great filter hypothesis prompts,
a number of important questions is mankind going to be able to
adequately and successfully respond to an unexpected challenge or is
the worst already in the past.
And the silence of the universe is a sign that where one of the few races to
have completed all the stages devised by the great filter.
Unfortunately, we can answer any of this to,
and the only thing we can do now is to brace up for a trial.
The universe has ins whatever it may be,